get 12 weeks of The Spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds and will
give you a 20 pound Amazon gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator coat UK
forward slash voucher
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
I'm Fraser Nelson each week during
lockdown we've been asking three of our
writers to read out what they've written
for the magazine this week we have James
Forsythe reading his cover story on
Boris Johnson's mission impossible to
rewire Whitehall
we've got Douglas Murray writing a
column about a leaked memo he's had from
an NHS chief suggesting what the
underlings might like to read to educate
themselves on culture wars and finally
Leith Arbuthnot's who went underground
to the various speakeasies and secret
theaters happening in London right now
first James Forsythe rewiring the state
Tobit has revealed what is wrong with
Whitehall it is never a good sign when
the government relaunched itself look
what happened in the end is treason may
his time in power as a real almost every
other week each one with diminishing
effect but over has been overhyped Boris
Johnson's to attempt to start again
isn't a mere rebranding exercise it is
not just about rehashing policy
proposals but about trying to tackle the
dysfunction at the heart of a state the
PM is attempting to use something past
he deserve ought to be an impossible job
to rewire the whole system Johnson has
tire on his site for years to get things
back on track and a commons majority but
there's a paradox at the heart of this
big reform project if he's so frank
almost brutal about the failings of
government have any pinning his hopes on
government to solve his country's
economic problems in normal
circumstances a politician's view of the
efficiency of government informs their
view on the role of a state the post-war
Labour government was animated by the
belief that the man in white [ __ ] knows
best and so the state became ever more
involved in both the economy and in
people's everyday lives
Margaret Thatcher and four individuals
were better judge of our own needs and
government and said about rolling back
the frontiers of a state visit number 10
things that the British mr. States is
deeply flawed dysfunctional even but it
is nevertheless relying on government
obviously a reformed client deliver the
changes it please are crucial to this
country's future prosperity if Michael
Gove fixes all service itself addison
through the majority of the country then
why isn't he proposing to cut this
flawed Leviathan down to size the
Batchelor Reagan approach would seem to
be more logical reaction to the failings
of government but is worth remembering
that when Reagan declared in his first
inaugural the
government was a problem not a solution
he caveat it with the phrase in this
crisis Reagan was still an admirer
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and the New
Deal it was a reminder of its
circumstances master in politics and in
the current situation government has to
become part of a solution the problem
Britain faces today are a far cry from
the 1980s one ally of the Prime Minister
sums up the mood as the machine is dead
let's build a new machine and advance
even before covert this country was in a
Productivity crisis and it is now
possible to improve productivity without
government involvement increasing
productivity requires improvements we
made a physical and digital
infrastructure and of a skills base and
those need public investment one of the
reasons Johnson is so keen will be
infrastructure projects is that he
thinks this is one area where the public
sector doesn't crowd out the private
sector but he has to stop allowing such
projects to waste so much time and money
can he succeed his is not the first
government to attempt to reform well but
two generations British politicians have
been trying to make the image of state
function better and with little success
someone has ordered a distraction from
the issues that the government should be
focusing on one observes it is always
easier to blame his on structures and to
solve problems with policy veterans of a
Cameron government the beginning to
chuckle a schadenfreude they regarded
Whitehall reform is the ultimate rabbit
hole for any prime minister to go down
and yet it remains true but nothing
significant can change until the
machinery of government functions
properly
I never close a crisis made one thing
clear it is that it currently does not
Johnson in circle believe that reforming
White has existential to his
government's prospects one Tori tells me
sorting out the state isn't an easy
Terek thing but Kees delivering on the
things that will keep our seats there
fear is about a state that can't deliver
then we swept out of office bite in 2024
by the appear of time for a change after
14 years of Tory rule so what would a
rewired government look like the heart
of the project of changes of a cabinet
office the departure of smart said well
as cabinet secretary national security
adviser is just a store there will be
limits fists revolution said rules
replacement will be a current or formal
and permanent secretary the first civil
service commission in what Warren
insisted on that but this bar bring in
an outsider matters less because the
role of a cabinets actually is about to
change significantly in the new
disposition the cabinet secretary is
most important role will be as head of a
civil service
numbers have no chosen candidate so this
will be a genuine competition but some
permanence actually is are not in a
serious contention not one-time things
the institutional response which moment
of Health and Social Care service crisis
has been deeply flawed so that perhaps
rules out because were mortal at the
Department of Health
Antonio may have opponents actually
evolve in some trade is another much tip
name is unlikely to get the job there's
no requirement the next cabinet
secretary to be a bright stick but
interesting the view in Whitehall is
that of the 40 or so permanent
secretaries only one bit beneath and
perhaps two more at breakfast the new
number temperaments actually Simon case
whose highly regarded will take on an
expanded role in this new system I
understand that the domestic policy
secretary through those disputes between
government departments will report to
him this team will have embedded in it
something akin to Tony Blair's Delivery
Unit his role will be to chase policy
across Whitehall ensuring that there is
follow from the government's commitments
at the same time a national security
Secretariat will report to David Frost
the Prime Minister's chief brexit
negotiator who is the new national
security adviser they set up will be in
place by the autumn cynics say that
reforming while it's being attempted
before
then it always fails there is a reason
to think that this time might be
different though prove it the virus has
been a test of governments and systems
of governments around the world
no one can look at the UK death toll
conclude that this must be one of the
best governed countries in the world it
is cleared in terms of public
administration we lack behind Germany
and far behind the Asian democracies
this realization means that the forces
of reform in Whitehall have been
strengthened and the force of
conservatism weakened as one sector of
state puts it crises provide an
opportunity to upend some of the things
that haven't worked in the past and the
secrets were pushing on the reform
agenda it's the inevitable public
inquiry into the government's handling
of clovis there'll be plenty presumes to
make but the machinery of government is
bound to coming for heavy fire
strengthening the case for change
ministers not accept that the state
really does need reform but it is failed
at stress-test
one of those intimately involved in the
government's coronavirus response tells
me people mean astonished at how often
much of the british state is every time
you look up close to check with part of
its functioning okay you find disaster
it's like leaning on what seems to be a
solid wartime finding it's rotten your
hand push it straight through Johnson
has been radicalized by the experience
I'm told he's much more interested in
reforming civil service than he was
pretty much but it's more important than
the effect the crisis had on ministers
is it its strength from the view of a
card or Whitehall high flies that change
is needed but the Civil Service can't
just go on congratulating itself I mean
a Rolls Royce machine this is why the 41
year old case is such an important
figure in this Whitehall read about
while at Meijer of his says he
represented a younger generation who
understand that things have gone awry
this younger generation is important but
there's no changes of Whitehall are
going to work unless they're a civil
servants who agree but they're necessary
reform is not something that can be
simply imposed by ministerial diktat
even more important when the shift in
structures is a shift in mindset
intended to accompany a more rigorous
examination is required over for
government policies of delivered returns
on money peninsula the government aims
to make data publicly available to
enable vast course correction but it is
far from achieving this take Lester the
corona virus testing native it is the
basis of locking down the city it's not
open to external examination the new
emphasis on data must properly
distinguish between data and modeling
facie is real analytical body it enables
robust discussion of what has worked and
what it's not modeling the far less
exact science in this crisis as in the
2008 financial crisis models would be
more of a hindrance than a help
curing this country's ills requires an
effective government but it will take a
realistic idea of what government could
do the failure of a test and tracer is a
reminder a government technology
projects can sound great but we deeply
flawed in practice the emphasis should
be on hiring government to get on with
doing the things that is best suited to
building infrastructure taking care of
public health and ensuring access to
education and skills training there's a
danger with this desire to use the state
will lapse back into tired thinking
there is something depressing about the
emphasis Johnson's putting on building
new schools in the North and the
Midlands if the government thinks are
one of the biggest problems of Education
in them it's the quality of a school
estate then it really is that ideas
levelling up has to mean more than just
building new schools and hospitals into
private places
rely on the effectiveness of government
is an uncomfortable place for any
central administration to be but this is
where Boris Johnson services to find
themselves his future is depended on his
ability to make government what better
that was James Forsythe now Douglas
Murray all the people who have made cash
in the past month
few can have raked it in like Robyn
D'Angelo since the death of George Floyd
the white America
academic and author of white fragility
has been absolutely milking it a term I
probably shouldn't use since Petter last
week declared milk a symbol of white
supremacy I might say she is absolutely
creaming it though by the time you read
this cream might be racist - in which
case it will join the British
countryside which was designated as
racist by the BBC's country file last
week a fact that I learned after opening
Google's homepage where I was educated
about the late black American drag queen
Marcia Johnson anyhow I mentioned
D'Angelo because even before her recent
rush of fame anyone wishing to employ
her to correct their opinions had to
shell out six thousand dollars an hour
or twelve thousand dollars for two hours
that is what a Angelou charged the
University of Kentucky last year for two
hour session on racial injustice I
imagine that she charges more for all
those CEOs now queuing up to hire the
Miss whiplash of anti racism to come up
to their offices and spend an afternoon
telling them how bad and worthless they
are then there are the book sales
ever since the Minnesota cop killed mr.
Floyd endless companies and individuals
have sent out reading lists instructing
us all of what to read each time
D'Angelo's 2018 work tops the list
consider a document I've just been
leaked from the office of the chief
executive of the Birmingham and Solihull
NHS mental health trust dated 5th of
June and titled inequalities and racial
discrimination it starts by claiming
that recent events in America have
highlighted once again the
discrimination and inequality
experienced by people of Bahm heritage
every day the three-page letter goes
it is not up to our bein colleagues to
make this right
they are quite honestly and
understandably fed up of repeatedly
telling their stories and not being
understood the author of this letter is
one Royce in Fallon Williams who in
these anti-racist times I ought to point
out is white she knows what to do I
write this to us all from what I now
know and understand to be an ignorant
and incompetent stance
she says whilst I remain ignorant and
incompetent I do now better understand
that I am culpable I have been complicit
she goes on to urge her equally
incompetent and ignorant colleagues to
take time to go up to bein colleagues
and say how are you and are you okay and
to really listen to what they say all of
which raises the question as such
anti-racists always do of what precisely
they got up to until the day before
yesterday on the third page of
self-flagellation miss Fallon Williams
suggests for works that her ignorant and
incompetent colleagues should read it is
the usual list though Fallon Williams
may be unaware that half of her
suggested texts are by white authors one
is the work by Peggy McIntosh of
Wellesley College unpacking the
invisible knapsack has been so often
cited over the three decades since it
was written that until reading it awhile
back I had assumed that there was
something there I was wrong the entire
work simply consists of a few pages of
assertions intended to demonstrate the
daily effects of white privilege the
first is I can if I wish arranged to be
in the company of people of my race most
of the
I'm assertion number 33 is I am not made
acutely aware that my shape bearing or
body odor will be taken as a reflection
on my race an assertion that only tempts
me to make a whole set of reflections on
the shape bearing and body odor of white
female academics from Wellesley but top
of Fallon Williams's reading list is
that work which while longer than
mackintoshes is in many ways still
flimsier the central assertion of white
fragility is that all white people are
racist white people who are aggrieved
being told that they are racist are said
by diangelo to be demonstrating white
fragility which is further demonstration
of their racism all of which leaves
white people in their entirety in that
conundrum faced by which is facing a
dunking in the village pond it is a game
of D'Angelo's creation which once
engaged in cannot be won except by her
herbs of course some good people are
getting carried away by battle of course
some good people are getting carried
along by all of this people of every
skin color who believe our society is
intrinsically racist and that as a
result everything must be understood
through the lens of skin colour others
of us also every skin colour beg to
differ not because we are racists or
think our societies can't be better but
because we think that what is being
demanded of us by the anti racism
professors and others is a racialist
hell of a fresh kind like the black
lives matter movement itself the social
justice typifies by the works of
Macintosh and D'Angelo is set up to be
all but uh opposable like those pea
studies departments that mysteriously
cropped up during the Cold War the
apparently impossible to oppose front
has deep destructive and yes Marxist
aims all the way behind it today this is
presented as though it is eminently
simple to download we must simply absorb
the right books correct our language
follow the instructions and otherwise
run the program well you can do or you
can refuse and I would strongly
recommend the latter approach for what
the race hucksters are offering is not
an upgrade of our societal software
rather there's is a program intended to
distort and to destroy the whole system
a system that may have its faults but
does not deserve the introduction of
such societal malware from the boardroom
to the NHS and everywhere else in
society I suggest people make sure they
understand the consequences of what they
are agreeing to be very very careful
before clicking accept all that was
Douglas Murray now leaf are both nerds
among the first to arrive was a Labour
grandi then others drifted over
academics musicians writers a nurse they
came from different directions some
looking shifty others excited the secret
meeting point was an inconspicuous pub
in North London queuing shoppers nearby
assumed the growing crowd was waiting to
get into the supermarket in groups of
five those gathered were led down a
suburban street to a derelict Leisure
Centre for one night only the gym had
been turned into a makeshift theatre the
audience of up to 30 people had
congregated to flick a collective V at
the social distancing measures and to
watch a hero of our time a three hander
adapted by hunch theater from the 1840
novel by Mikhail Lermontov in
I'd the theater it was as if the past
four months had been a very weird dream
audience members kissed one another on
the cheek without compunction shared
wine and finally settled shoulder to
shoulder on the floor to watch there was
not a face mask in sight since the
lockdown began on the 23rd of March
britain's cultural life has moved online
gigs are streamed and books launched on
zoom' art made in captivity Zrii laid an
anemic photos on social media for some
the transition to digital has been
intuitive beneficial even the number of
people who participated in this year's
digital only hay festival was almost
doubled the number who normally buy
tickets but broadly it's been a dire
time for people in the arts many are
freelance and are neither on furlough
nor qualify for government support
incomes have vanished overnight a recent
study by the forecaster Oxford Economics
found that coronavirus will wallop
Britain's creative industries twice as
hard as it will impact the economy
overall more than 400,000 jobs are
expected to go and revenues are forecast
to drop by 74 billion pounds behind
these cosmic figures are real people who
are out of work or soon will be and who
are confronting an uncertain future
while the country is gearing up to open
on the 4th of July
many galleries clubs and concert venues
will not Cameron Mackintosh has said
that he doesn't expect West End theatres
to reopen until 2021 with the situation
as bleak as this it is little wonder
that some in the arts are beginning to
rebel one of the organizers of last
week's clandestine play who would rather
not be named has been taken aback by the
over conformist attitude that has swept
the arts world since the starts for
pandemic people have signed over their
health to the state is if they can't
make up their own minds about what risk
to take staying indoors isn't living
life under lockdown has been reduced to
a zoom meeting it's on a healthy and
atomizing I find it hilarious that the
left wants to be on the side of Tory
laws and regulations when asked if she
worries about audience members infecting
one another and going back into the
community she points out that everything
is risk life is risk the most important
thing shouldn't be safety
wall breaking isn't just happening in
rarefied theater circles invitations to
raves and club nights are going well
viral George hull a veteran rave
promoter believes there will be more
illegal parties this summer than there
have been in decades it's already
happening up and down the country Jen
said kids are quite a spirited lot and
they've been stripped of the option of
going to an overpriced club night or
festival so it stands to reason they'll
go to unlicensed raves listen out for
the new sounds that will inevitably
bubble up from these sweaty incubators
of creativity just as acid house did in
the 1980s one quarantine party organizer
reveals he's bought antibody tests from
Island for people to take as they enter
the warehouse where he'll host an
invite-only night dedicated to general
debauchery and the music of Sidney
Bechet he's also considered getting a
dog as a bouncer as their rumored to be
decent coronavirus detectors the science
suggests this is bollocks the night
before the play in North London a drop
spin on whatsapp maps the way to a new
speakeasy you pitch up at a central
London townhouse ring the doorbell pay
20 pounds and are led to a series of
darkened rooms the crowd is young posh
coqui and cosmopolitan as the night
kisses on the bar begins to feel more
like a nightclub deprived of touch for
months on end people brush one another's
arms and stand a little too close or
gathered by the speakers to be blasted
by music it sweeps the COBIT cobwebs
away for obvious reasons it's hard to be
sure quite how much is going on behind
closed doors polls have shown the
lockdown to be surprisingly popular many
in the arts are young left-wing remain
voters who approve of the measures or
believe they're not tough enough recent
research by LSE found that levers and
those on the right a group not
over-represented in the arts tend to be
more skeptical of the lockdown an active
friend confirms that everyone she knows
in the industry is plain nice not as a
mark of respect for the Conservatives
but out of duty to the NHS yet the
longer actors and others in the arts are
deprived of their livelihoods the more
clandestine activity will spread it's
not just that people need to earn their
cross
or even that they understandably don't
want to retrain in lockdown friendly
trades it's that many feel creatively
famished
of course this isn't the first time that
the arts have suffered as a result of
edicts from on high theaters were closed
by Parliament in 1642 having been deemed
hot houses of lascivious mirth and
levity sounds great the ban was lifted
after those in the industry insisted
they cleaned up their act
we have purged our stages of all obscene
and scurrilous Jass insisted the writer
of the 1643 actor's remonstrance behind
the iron curtain soviet hippies stole
coils from phones to string their
electric guitars and play band music
when war broke out in 1939 London
theaters closed but soon reopened under
public pressure the arts adapted to the
rationing of costumes makeup and paper
and some London troops performed in the
safer provinces the Old Vic for instance
took a production of Macbeth through
Welsh mining villages in London theater
goers prided themselves on their
resilience we're no cowards
Blythe spirit opened in 1941 at the
Piccadilly the audience gamely climbed
over rubble to reach the theatre
audiences today are more fearful just 15
percent of regulars are booking tickets
according to research by indigo and
there has been no noticeable clamor from
the public to jumpstart Britain's
cultural life yet how long will this
attitude last if livestreams may be
supplemented by the odds no contact play
continue to be all that's on offer into
October might we not finally hear cries
of covert be damned at the peak of the
lockdown in April the inveterate rule
breaker and performance artist and beam
left her home at dawn to put up an
installation on the foreshore of the
Thames at the time the messaging from
the government was almost monosyllabic
stay home etc Bean says she had the
strange feeling as she put up the art
that what she was doing was much more
transgressive than past installations
many of which had led to run-ins with
police in other parts of the country
communities of artists are coming
together to organise gatherings and
performances
despite the lockdown but there's a lot
of jumpiness about one gallery owner was
going to
host an opening but got cold feet when
word got round that she might be
planning some sort of rebellion Rafael
toad as a musician was ticked off by the
police when he and his family formed a
string quartet on their Street the
copper listen to us play for 15 minutes
then at the end he accused us of
incitement together it was a great plod
phrase todd's explains unlikely as it is
that audiences will pack out big-name
venues soon how many more musicians and
actors will be forced to break the law
in order to find employment a community
that in many ways seems to have
forgotten how to defy the state might
however need some lessons there are a
few directors better placed to remind us
of the art of disobedience from the man
behind the unauthorized North London
performance vladimir Sherbourne who was
once a key member of a celebrated
underground Eastern European theatre
company whose productions were regularly
shut down by the police as William cook
wrote last month the old way of doing
things wasn't working for everyone
anyway moving performances into disuse
spaces car parks leisure centres
warehouses and making shows more
immersive and mobile could attract new
audiences and free up the art form the
Lermontov play had two acts after the
interval the audience was led to an
empty swimming pool which had become the
Russian spa town of Kislovodsk everyone
climbed down rickety iron ladders and
watched the drama come to an end the
story finished like all Russian dramas
worth their salt with a dual high above
the pool a skylight measured the dimming
of the day the play was a tour de force
not only because of the faultless
performances an ingenious direction but
because of the extraordinary setting and
the ferocity of the world that the play
had kept at bay the spell lingered for
hours afterwards made even more potent
by the copious shots of homemade vodka
distributed free to audience and actors
alike hookah roused into the night was
the organiser frightened of being caught
she shrugs I'm not personally worried
about getting busted it's obviously
risky but I would be prepared to go to
prison for putting on a play that was
leaf our buffness
thank you for listening to this episode
of spectator out loud and do let us know
what you think of this under other
podcasts you can email us on podcast at
spectator dot co dot UK it's always
great to hear from you good or bad and
get ideas as to how we can improve our
podcasts in the future thanks for
listening again and thanks to our
producer Cindi you
get 12 weeks of The Spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds and will
give you a 20 pound Amazon gift voucher